في مقابله خاصه بها صحيفه الفرنسيه قال
وزير الخارجيه القطري محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني ان الاسباب المقدمه لمقاطعتي
مونديال قطر 2022 ليست صعبه
واضاف رئيس الدبلوماسيه القطريه ان هناك
الكثير من النفاق في هذه الهجمات على قطر
الروايه يتم ترويج لها من قبل عدد قليل
جدا من الناس في 10 بلدان على الاكثر
والتي لا تمثل على الاطلاق بقيه الكوكب
والحقيقه ان العالم يتطلع الى هذا
الاحتفال حيث تم بيعه اكثر من 97% من
التذاكر ومن بين الدول العشر التي اشترت
اكبر عدد من التذاكر نجد ودولا اوروبيه
على غرار فرنسا وانجلترا والمانيا
على سؤالي ليمون عن توقع حضور مراقبين
لحدوث ما يسمى باصدام الثقافات بين
المشجعين حول العالم وقطر ذكر وزير
الخارجيه القطري ان العالم كله مرحبا به
في قطر وكل ما يطلبه القطريون هو ان يحترم
المشجعون قوانينه ونواميس وعدت هذا البلد